thinking what about you Jenna Jillian
podcast we're talk about the Jenna do
things amongst the other things this
episode of judging podcast is brought to
you by Credit Karma right now guys check
your credit score for free and get on
your way to improve your credit score
with Credit Karma text Jenna Julian to
eighty nine eight hundred to download
the free app you guys will not regret it
this is the best way to monitor your
credit score and don't pay for your
credit credit where we can get afraid
don't pay for it
don't good ditchin Jenna thank you
running us up open your mouth huh I
guess are you good on your team I was
gonna fix it no you guys could see
you're a bit far I would like to know
that Jenna casually brought marbles in
and thought I wouldn't notice a snowman
like it was a movie and it was heat
marbles as a snack well I was just
eating and he was just sitting and
staring at me like and I was just trying
to eat real fast so that you come in in
podcast and I was like alright little
bunny know just sneak you in there and
Julian won't notice because I could see
I think that him and Jenna look at me
like what very cute I just wanna see my
old lion I felt like he deserves some a
long time sometimes ya know he needs
some marble time that's for sure he gets
kind of sad if he doesn't have it he
literally just wants to sit on my lap
all day so I mean I can accommodate that
at times I mean yeah he's uh yeah he's I
mean he's a little guy he needs a long
time
Kermit is just sitting in the living
room on her bag chair crichton's for
frying broken eyes tail no he's yeah
with his broken tail he's just sitting
there chilling powder alone yeah he
doesn't like when we podcast yeah that
none of the dogs like when we come in
here in podcast
although I will note that at least they
stopped that thing where they scratch at
the door for yeah that was not fun you
guys remember that at least also before
we had a podcast room you guys remember
when oh my oh hell would be breaking
loose while we were podcasting peaches
would be Bart peach would be barking
Kermit would be [ __ ] crawling it
Jenna there's a podcast so when we did
is Billy Ray and and Sarah Palin
Kermit's like right here though
so at least we have it sort of set up
now man
today we wanted to cover something that
we are a few weeks removed from and that
is the Ronda Rousey Holly Holm fight we
left town we first of all the weekend
that that fight happened we had already
recorded our podcast for the next week
and then we went out of town so we've
had kind of a couple weeks to marinate
and not talk about it so we can now talk
about it yeah we have to talk about it
whoo we've done a few dedicated UFC
podcasts when we felt it was right and I
feel like this is absolutely one of
those times so this is going to be a UFC
dedicated podcast mm a dedicated podcast
so if you guys aren't interested in that
you can click on away right now so we
don't waste your time but um we stay I
won't waste your time I don't I kidding
she was I kidding
ah yuck for those who don't know UFC 193
between Ronda Rousey who was previously
the bantamweight female champion of the
UFC undefeated 135 unparalleled thought
to be the best female fighter on earth
by far judo and Juno bronze medalist
Olympian not just Olympian medalist she
had wrecked through the entire division
so much so that everyone including
myself thought it was going to be a
while till any real competition happened
and then Holly Holm who is a former
professional boxer and kickboxer came in
huge underdog and knocked Rousey out
with ease like she battered her and then
knocked her up and I would I would say
it's it's pretty safe to say that kind
of took everyone by surprise the
internet was feeling all types of ways
and that week I kind of wanted to cover
that part of it to just you know the
fight itself obviously but the aftermath
both on their end the fans end and
moving forward what it's going to be
like which i think is is a very
interesting situation and it's to say
the least I think moving backwards just
off the top yeah the first time that I
saw Holly Holm fight we were in Austin
Texas we were we were in a hotel we were
in a hotel
in Austin and use like two years ago is
it more than two years ago and you know
we're ordering room service and
naturally like I find the local MMA
fight that's on TV it up because you
have like five channels and we found I
remember it was like X fights or some
really small promotion I'll have to look
on Holmes record on Sherlock but it was
one of her really small promotion fights
and I remember
Efrain Escudero was fighting back hard
to
that's what anyway home was fighting and
we were watching her me like oh you know
what she's pretty solid on her feet like
if she kind of developed a little bit
and got stronger she'd be a great Rousey
matchup I well that was not my reaction
was Myron because your reaction was sort
of like oh you know not you said that
exactly to me like if she you know works
really hard maybe that would be a good
match like I didn't think she was there
yet
of course I'm there but I was sort of
looking at her like [ __ ] you drunk like
no like no way yes no but I mean overall
we were both sort of relatively
underwhelmed with the idea that she
could fight somebody and defeat someone
like Ronda Rousey I think absolutely and
I think I just remember feeling very
under known and I think I think the
biggest reason for that was just a lot
of well it's not only that but like a
lot of Holmes fights leading up to
Rousey she is technically great like
when she hits the pads the mitts
the the bag or she's fighting someone
who's can and she's you know technically
got her kicks looked sharp her foot
works really nice technically you look
at her and you're like on paper you're a
great fighter you could be one of the
best in the UFC but that it goes beyond
that because then you look at how her
punches impact people and she I for a
while kind of thought she had pillow
fists which mean her punches would land
but it wouldn't really hurt people that
much I wouldn't damage them she had
great technical abilities but there was
not a lot of oomph behind her strikes
obvious pillow fist it's like that
killer pillow fists but I mean that
wasn't to say that she couldn't improve
I always thought there was room for her
improve and you know she did
and obviously when she goes in against
someone like Rousey in your mind when
you play that match up in your head
you're like well Rousey is so intense
she's going to come at you she's gonna
grab you push you against the fence if
she's good
to like and that all happened so fast
and everyone aroused these fights now
you're like home is just she I just feel
like athletically it doesn't feel like
she can handle that
but we were so wrong we were so wrong
like she came in and did the best job in
the world of keeping the distance which
is what a striker needs to do against
the grappler kept a distance and just
picked her apart like Rousey had said
like it you know there's a recent ESPN
interview that came out with Rousey like
this week no no in the interview she was
like I was out on my feet from the first
trick like I was just trying to survive
Rousey said that mom that's crazy
Jenna was like like the rest of the
Internet's just mind-blowing that
happened she's screaming we're watching
a screaming breeze I wasn't ok let me
clarify what that means because I am a
fan of Ronda were cheering you were like
oh my god it was just an oh my god yeah
I'm a I'm a fan of Ronda Rousey I as a
former athlete we're both athletes it's
incredible
whether this person you like them or not
it is incredible to watch someone excel
at that level in any form of athletics
it's just like it's a pleasure to watch
it's incredible to be in the presence of
someone that is that elite yeah and so I
am a fan of hers for that some of the
the stuff that she says and some of her
personal beliefs I'm not sure a hundred
percent agree with her like she's very
polarizing you can say whatever the [ __ ]
you want and do whatever the [ __ ] you
want as long as you work hard into your
job which she does better than anybody
else ever and I expected Ronda to win
the fight only because in my mind it was
hard for me to imagine her not being
able to get Holly home and a point where
she could you know toss her to the
[ __ ] ground and at that point I was
like all right you know Holly's gonna if
you're a boxer and a kickboxer and
you're on your [ __ ] back you're about
to get your own bro yeah so that that
was my anticipation but I think I speak
for a lot of people when you see someone
who is that great it doesn't really
matter what's happening if they're
starting to [ __ ] get flustered and
[ __ ] like this is like some of the
most exciting
things that you can watch whether or not
you like Rhonda or don't are your fan or
you're not it was incredibly exciting I
would put it in my top five favorite
fights that I've ever watched usually
there's always the thing that goes um
everyone has a plan until they get
punched you know yeah
Rousey college I was you told me to like
literally sit down and shut up like
multiple times because I was like
standing on the couch screaming like oh
you're trying to like take it in Mariana
just like absorb what was going but you
can vote that I was living losing your
minds
yeah Oh like hyped and excited I
couldn't control my body yeah I know I
was it was absolutely like my hands were
going no he was so excited yeah yeah
yeah but to watch that and I was taken
aback because the last time that I like
really paid attention to Holly Holm was
you know two three years ago when we
started fighting in Austin and she was
just sort of boxing this person and I
was relatively underwhelmed so I was so
like my whole world and mind was like
this is so [ __ ] exciting I'm just in
this for the sport like I love the sport
and this is like moments like that
fights like that is like what you
[ __ ] live for it's it's you know i
I've followed Rousey for many years I
followed her long before she was in the
UFC you know and I interviewed her a
couple times and I've just I've been
following her and it's a very
interesting you know route the way she's
built his path and become the most
famous fighter the UFC has ever had I'm
fair I'm fairly certain I could say that
right now like they invested so much in
her and they still are you know
obviously she lost it sucks but you know
for her and everything but the UFC
believes in her more than I felt I've
ever seen before and and studying her
and like watching her fight so many
times I you know as every other MMA fan
who knows what they're watching you you
you understand a fighter and you
understand what can beat them whether
it's just a concept or it's an actual
fighter that you think is a good match
like for me I never knew of a single
fighter that was a good match
for her even's Chris cyborg I always
thought the best well here's the thing I
always thought the best oh yes I can't I
can't no I don't want to interrupt you
but I keep thinking about those old
conversations where we would just die
laughing at the idea of Chris cyborg
fighting her and how Dana White that one
soundbite of him being like Chris cyborg
said she will die if she drops me good
yeah absolutely it's not a good match
knowing you'd never thought anyone was a
good match yeah but in my mind I thought
okay to beat Ronda Rousey someone needs
to have incredibly technical hands and
kicks and they need number one out of
everything is to have the skill and the
athleticism to keep distance the entire
fight keep the distance from Rousey so
they can attack me outside now
I never thought Holly Holm was that girl
to do that I thought there was going to
be someone else come on but in like even
when you when you propose a fight like
like cyborg everyone's like Oh cyborg
Rousey it's going to be the greatest
make it happen I've never thought that
was an intriguing fight just because the
cyborgs gonna blitz creek rousey with
her giant crazy powerful punches and
strikes and that's what Rousey wants she
wants you to draw into her game so she
can toss I thought she did too batch go
ahead yes exactly you get someone riled
up you get them wanting to knock you out
so bad can't thank God oh did that too
right that's another did it right away
so you know I never thought cyber was as
intriguing as the the possibility of
someone who could do what home actually
did and she did it and that's like a
crazy thing for me to see um you know I
feel I feel mixed about it because I've
you know I've watched her for so long
and sheep she really got [ __ ] up you
know she in an interview this week she
was like I can't even eat an apple for
three weeks I don't know how I'm gonna
[ __ ] take damage and practice and she
like she's [ __ ] up what her fate what
do you mean like she got hit in the jaw
no she can't eat an apple she got beat
up so bad like her jaw yeah
like basically she's just really really
any soft stuff she's alright
the point the point is your job the
point is the fall from grace which is so
she was so high and now she is so low
yeah and I think that transition is
something that will define you well
knowing Ronda I don't know her
personally but knowing how much she's
put out there about how hard she works
for and how much she wants
this in her life yeah I cannot imagine
her taking her first loss and being like
oh you know I guess I'm just gonna plug
in go on with life like she's gonna come
back and just absolutely but it's not
the scariest person that's ever existed
yet but you understand that like that
like a loss the way she lost after how
high she was riding it's not just her
first loss like this is so much more
than one loss or her first loss it's
like it it really really got underneath
of her skin and devastated every part of
her so she's got to build her way back
up to just to just zero to start
training and preparing for fight and
then she's got a you know block out the
fact that she got whupped you know and
lost her title the way she did so she
can slowly get back up because you know
this is the type of fight where I feel
like an athlete of Rousey's caliber
could lose and then never be the same
because mentally you can't come back
from that I'm not saying you can't but
I'm not doing it's a big possibility
that someone cannot come back from that
it really does Rousey could but it's
it's definitely a career-defining moment
agreed yeah I mean it's going to be very
interesting to see the rematch obviously
Dana White's a big proponent of the
rematch yeah well let's talk about some
of the reactions of people because I
know immediately after this is not my
reaction or anyone on Twitter's reaction
this was Miesha Tate reaction who was
hosting a watching party at like a
gentlemen's club in Vegas and she got on
the mic and was like all right everybody
knows she got her [ __ ] ass beats
about time like I'm pretty sure I'm the
next in line for that fight something to
that extent
along with some expletives in a strip
club but um it's it's not this is sort
what we talked about this you're like no
it's good news for everyone because now
she's been beaten so it was calm but it
was right yeah but I was like well it's
bad news for someone like me she Tate
who you know otherwise maybe would have
had a rematch but now there's home and
Rousey that need a but but I always
thought that Miesha Tate
after losing twice to Rousey why would
she want a rematch with Rousey she just
wants a rematch with the title that
should be good for her now she can fight
for the title and have it not be against
Rousey right now I agree but I'm
I'm saying like in theory though people
now have to wait for like that it throws
a wrench into everyone's match between
absolutely Rousey's absolutely yeah it's
it's not the best but at the same time
it's great absolutely for everybody it's
it's not the greatest in the short term
but in the long term it is great for
everybody yeah yeah yeah big time
but people's reactions on Twitter ranged
from everything of like oh my god I'm so
devastated you know Ronda Rousey's my
favorite person in the world to people
being like oh she deserved it because
she talks [ __ ] and she's too cocky yeah
and I had something to say about that
Jamie hates that [ __ ] I don't like it
either really I mean not at all okay so
here's the thing oh and this is this is
really just me trying to do my best at
explaining something that is not an easy
concept to understand it took me a while
to understand it as an MMA fan and it's
something that a lot of people a lot of
people still don't cry quite get and
that is fighters need to sell fights and
is it they're paid in proportionate in
proportion to how many pay-per-views are
sold so if you're a fighter okay and
you're fighting someone and you have no
animosity towards that person personally
you just know you have to fight them to
get paid you benefit from creating hype
drama whatever it is you know creating
some sort of animosity so people can
believe it's a good story that you're
fighting someone you don't like or they
said something that offended you
personally whatever it is think about
every big fight ever in anything boxing
MMA there's you know the biggest fights
in the world have had build-up that have
sold the fights they've made the fights
legendary they've made them live on
forever
think about Chael Sonnen he is the
master of it McGregor is another and
really enjoy it but Gregor is very prime
at illegal wrestling Gregor is I would
relate McGregor to Muhammad Ali in the
weight in a way he sells a fight you
don't I mean I agree but well people
don't they choose not to see that
because you know they see the WWE they
see professional wrestling and they're
like I get that that's a show I know and
there's a shine line right yeah
that yes we're watching a real sport yes
you are watching real athletes you are
also still watching entertainment no
it's an it's a business that needs like
money and so yeah I just I just want to
like I finished it now I'm not trying to
cut you up um so what I'm saying is like
what Rousey is was was great at that you
know she wasn't rate at first but as she
got better she got higher up on the
totem pole of literally the world not
just MMA the entire kind of media of the
world you know people were recognizing
her she had millions of followers like
she was in movies she got better at
promoting fights maybe to the point
where she kind of turned a lot of people
off but you understand that that's still
doing her job she's still promoting the
fight if she does something like pushing
someone at a press conference or says
something like she did on Instagram with
home or whatever and it bugs you you're
gonna want to [ __ ] go pay and watch
that fight on Saturday to watch her get
her ass kicked because she got you know
she got you riled up and I feel like
fortunately the reality it's the
realities and you made such a good point
when you said it's an entertainment
business before anything yes it's a
sport but the entire business is based
on entertainment it's a pay-per-view for
Christ's sake like it's entertainment
um and so when Rousey was really kind of
off-putting to a lot of people leading
up to Holly Holm saying a bunch of [ __ ]
and then they're like oh she deserve it
she was a you know [ __ ] at Wayans and
all this like dude she sold so many
[ __ ] pay-per-views you have no idea
yes she got her ass kicked but they got
paid you know like that's one thing that
I have frustration with like when I
score on Twitter and I see I'm glad
Rousey got her bell rung like you can be
glad that you know you don't like her
and you glad she lost but don't say she
deserved it no one deserves to get beat
up you know no one deserves get hurt she
was clearly hurt she was down and people
were kicking her and that that kind of
hit me the wrong way because that's
something that people don't get it's
that Rousey is not a bad person
she may do things you don't agree with
she's not like a person who pushes
people huh she's selling a fight you
know what I mean she's doing her job
that was that's my gripe thank you for
letting me kind of get on my soapbox
about that no I agree 100% and you know
the people that are saying that are just
like
this just [ __ ] open your brain for
like three seconds god that's how I feel
yeah and you know what when you sell a
fight like that you get paid like Rousey
got paid she lost but she got paid and
you better believe she went home and
went on her credit card map and was like
oh yeah Julie
this looks good I can open some credit
cards I can get my credit score up and
you can too now you can go get the
credit karma app by texting Jenna Julian
289 800 right now get a free app from
Credit Karma you will have home
affordability calculator you'll have
debt repayment calculators you'll have
all the tools notifications guidelines
to help you raise your credit score and
it's going to be all for free like there
are so many countless websites out there
that try to bait you in with credit card
fees and things that you say hey let's
get your own credit score and is much
like not fun as it is to like manage
your credit score it is so important
because that stays your through your
child like it's your first child and
it's so hard to improve but it's easy to
[ __ ] up so Credit Karma is there to help
you for free just think about that too
late there's no there's literally no
reason you're not downloading the credit
card app while you listen to this
because hey it's free so if you don't
like it whatever but be you all you have
to do is gain you have to gain the tools
to improve your credit score have an
accurate reading on your credit score
and do it all for free text Jenna Julian
eighty nine eight hundred right now get
the free app thanks Credit Karma for
sponsoring us Credit Karma and I was
going to say before we took a break
there for a second
um I don't know this for sure I'm just
creating an idea for a second that I
imagine if you're Ronda Rousey and you
know not that long ago Dana White said
there will never be women in the UFC and
now there are and now they're headlining
fights I imagined that whatever pressure
you know John Jones or somebody [ __ ]
DC they feel to promote fights and push
fights imagine what it's like to be
Ronda Rousey looking great the burden on
her shoulders to not only be the best
stay the best but to prove that Dana
should keep giving her these headlining
fights when she cleared out the
vision like people at some point
obviously have gotten to where you're
like is it worth watching this if she's
just gonna keep winning I already know
what's gonna happen
and hurt relentlessly saying I'm willing
to let people hate me and not like me
and all of that in order to do what's
right for my career and what's right for
the sport and respect this as a business
this is how people earn their livelihood
and I have to play the game you know I
only imagine that the pressure on her to
promote fights and to remain at her best
all the time is crushing the pressure on
Ronda Rousey is something that no UFC
fighter has gone through tonight nothing
has been the same and you made an
absolutely incredible point selling
fights for Rousey is even more
life-or-death than any other fighter in
the UFC even the big-time ones because
she's selling an entire sport for the
women he's representing the gender in
the UFC she was the first you know fight
urge you know we were there Liz
Carmouche it was very of 2012 on that
fight time she had hurt like in a
standing [ __ ] choke she had her back
Rousey stood up Carmouche had it had a
figure-four body lock and she was going
for the rear naked she was kind of
cranking her neck and it looked like she
could have finished and then Rousey
dumped her but it was it was a crazy
fight I think it was February 2012 yeah
right yeah or 13 I can't I think it
might've been 13 either way we were
there for Rousey has been the pioneer
for women in MMA and she continues to be
you know the reason Holly Holm even has
a title right now not just because she
beat Rousey but is because of Rousey you
know Rousey was huge huge proponent in
that so keep that in mind when you're
like why is she trying to sell a fight
so hard well that's why yeah because
we're not too long ago Dana like your
boss was telling was telling the world
no women in the UFC so I want to touch
on moving forward cuz I have some
thoughts well I want to point out that
the first thing that I noticed was
everyone was like oh holly holm's on
steroids clearly tester oh yeah well
that's natural I mean that's no pun
intended
big fight like that in an upset you're
sure I saw a very long I don't know why
I watched so much of it but like
immediately after soda you did you wash
ok I remember that I found on YouTube a
guy claiming that Holly Holmes like
clearly is on steroids and a lot of the
majority of the video is just a zoomed
in picture of her bikini bottom like of
her vagina basically and hideously
analyzes like all she has a larger
clitoris here you can see from Gears of
anabolic steroid well that clearly the
medical profession so we have all of you
ladies out there this is permanent so if
you if you want to be good at sports and
stuff you can't Easter it's because it
will dramatically alter the shape and
size of your clitoris I bet you didn't
think you're gonna hear that sense it
was just like that no it's it's that's
exactly what dedicated um I don't really
need to go into my thoughts on steroid
use in sports because it's it's
pointless it's not gonna do me any
favors great but but I'm also not going
to see her and say I know for a fact
that Holly's clean cuz I don't know that
not nobody knows except probably but
moving well that's that's true and I'm
glad you pointed that out that right
after she won in such amazing fashion
people were like oh well she juiced up
but I wanted to talk about can we move
on
ok I wanted to talk about Rousey moving
forward like what she should be doing in
my opinion moving forward I for a long
time in a party of I'd say a decent
amount of people who thought she was
with the wrong camp Edmund Tarr Verdean
is her coach and and she's claimed this
week she that she's going to stick with
him and whatever I think that's a bad
camp for her just because the reason
Edmund Harvard ian is in any way
successful if you even want to call him
that is because Ronda Rousey now when
you look at a fighter coach relationship
that should never be the relationship
the relationship should be a fighter
seeks out a coach or has a coach seek
them out because they are a proven
professional who is bred other
professionals to succeed in that sport
before
edmond Tarver dean is not that guy greg
jackson is that guy other people are you
know other giant really popular coaches
around the United States and I would
they are that guy I was gonna ask you
where do you think she should go because
I was going to say greg jackson so she
can't holland homes with greg jackson
but there's plenty there's so many other
camps out there with reputa coaching
that have bred champion after champion
and eminent are Verdean is someone who
has come up so short on teaching Ronda
Rousey to stand up she needs to be
taught and print perfecting her on her
feet because I love Joe Rogan to death
but you know for a while he was he was
high on Ronda Rousey's stand up game and
I had never understood that you know I
understand he's a big fan of her and she
got by with the stand up but she has
never had advance stand up and she needs
advanced stand up she needs to improve
her footwork her strikes like everything
that involves striking on your feet you
need to get better at and you can't do
it with an introvert II and that's just
my opinion okay if for whatever reason
anyone who were talking about is
watching this podcast I'm just a fan all
right I'm talking about what I think and
I genuinely think that you know and I'm
not the first person to say so you
remember when Ronda Rousey's mom went
public about Edmond he's not the
greatest guy and he's clearly come up
short in this in this coaching aspect
and obviously you know she loses a big
fight and then I come here and
everyone's like you know get a new coach
it sounds like you know you're dumping
your coach it's like fair-weathered fan
kind of [ __ ] no that's not it like I've
thought this for a while even when she
was winning hmm do you well couple
things let me just gather my sorry that
was a lot I've been talking a lot I'm
sorry no you're good I just need to make
my thoughts happen um I want to just
draw a parallel really quickly to what
you said to any other sport yeah
basically imagine let's let's take
baseball or softball which we're both
familiar with imagine that you're a
really great player as you know a young
adult and then you know you make it to
the show and you all of a sudden want
the the coach of the Red Sox to be your
coach different because it's a team
sport but what we're talking about is
essentially the per
that taught you when you were coming up
and then you got really good now this
person should be your coach forever I'm
I disagree with i'ma firmly I'm a firm
across the board in all athletics I
think what what my dad was my coach for
a long time
and when I was a you know young girl he
basically looked at me in the face and
was like I can't be your coach anymore
and I was like eh why dad and he goes
because you need a real close okay no I
hear your points make good points oh no
I'm not deciding no no this is good I'm
in the I'm in the school fraud that
however good Ronda Rousey was in her
first whatever 7 UFC fights hmm she
could have been better with any other
coach okay so you can't go and say
Edmond travertine is a reason she got
her come up or he taught her any
anything she was in an Olympic medallist
in judo okay you take that she was
already an MMA fighter she went to the
Glendale Fight Club with Edmonds Harvard
Ian and she started winning because
she's Ronda goddamn Rousey okay she's
incredibly skilled she's a great fighter
and she felt comfortable there and I'm
not I'm not anyone to say that's a bad
thing all I'm saying is that it was a
big glass ceiling like she could have
gone way way higher and still can with
different coaching it's been like I'm
sorry anyone who knows anything about
MMA kickboxing striking and you watch
Ronda Rousey in striking practice or
sparring or shadow boxing like it's just
a parent she doesn't have the advanced
skills that could have been taught to
her at a camp where that coaching was
available okay and now I want to adjust
the baseball thing because we said this
earlier MMA is it's very different from
other sports there are a lot of reasons
one of the biggest reasons is just kind
of the unregulated training which I
think will change soon because of all
the injuries I think Dana White's going
to put his foot down and start to
control the camps just so injuries done'
cuz right now it's like he hires UFC
fighter right and he's like I'm gonna
book you for a fight in May then he's
like see you in May like do whatever you
do my god there's no regulation there
they go to whatever camp they're
comfortable they train however much they
want and they come fight and I think
when it comes to like MMA Ronda like she
was Freedent signed to one team she
could go anywhere and even if
one sign I want to be she you just leave
that to me they don't sign contracts I
mean at least I don't know that they do
but it's not like you're signed with the
Red Sox and then you want to coach or
coach from the Reds like you're not
signed anywhere you're a little too free
to train throughout the week and weekend
however or wherever you want you just
need to make the connection and do it so
in in essence Rousey can and could have
always gone elsewhere yeah my next
question for you is I imagine that if
you're Ronda Rousey she strikes me as an
incredibly loyal person you lure you
he's smart
you know you'll nother one sorry I saw
jury assignment about the jewelry
jewelry saddest joy yet this message was
brought to you by DJ accounting 305 on
section um she strikes me as a very
loyal person I have to imagine that she
feels like she should if it's not broke
don't fix it
up until this point working with her
coach clearly works for her and you know
I think you make really valid points and
I'm sure other people feel the same way
or have even expressed to her you know
yeah um do you think it would be more
damaging to her at this point in her
career and her life given that she just
lost her first fight to switch coaches
because that is not a light easy thing
to do and do you think that she
personally would be able to sit with the
decision that she's putting her career
over any personal ties that she has
something I have to imagine that that
coach would feel very slighted if now
after her first loss she was like [ __ ]
this I'm out new coach here's a problem
I think there's a lot but there's a lot
of gray area there of like feelings and
personal relationships and loyalty and
your career in your life and your mental
capacity for change no it's even it's a
good it's a good question do you think
it would help her or hurt her
in what ways in choosing coaches yeah
well in short my answer is 100% Halper
okay and long it's very difficult for
you to separate personal and business
especially in a sport when you you know
you bleed and sweat with people every
single day you create a bond you
with a coach that you there like your
dad yeah except this all the time
they've surveyed kids who are the most
important people in your life God mom
dad coach absolutely okay
I'm not not trying to discount that it's
hard to separate that but at a certain
point Rousey you know I'm sure anyone
I'm not saying Rousey specifically but
anyone who's had a meteoric rise to fame
you've weeded out people in your life
that's just how it goes like you weed
out people you meet new people you kind
of change your circle right now is a
moment for Rousey where as much as she's
got this bond with her coach she needs
to look past that and think logically
and I know I know she's a very prideful
and loyal person and I respect her
1 million percent but I do think it
would benefit her greatly for her to
look a little bit just even just
hypothetically look a little bit beyond
the relationship and the personal aspect
of Edmund and her and you know think you
know think one day just go home with
mochi and just hang out and be like hey
what was that been doing before I was
fighting ok ok I'm nothing it would know
the answer is nothing and there's
nothing like do you know no because
nothing he wasn't doing he wasn't making
waves he wasn't a guy coaching people
who were you know like Chevy's the
bottom line is there's coaches and camps
throughout the United States like
everywhere where the coaches have been
coaching champs so hypothetically if
Rhonda had gone to like team alpha-male
or somewhere else where they have bred
successful fighters for a long time and
then you know she leaves because she
loses and she wants to change she's not
going to feel like I'm ruining this
entire camp because I'm their only one
that should never be the thought of the
fighter you should just think about
yourself so when she's you don't I mean
so she's leaving if she you know if she
leaves Edmond she's left with the guilt
of like we're all he has was me well
that's wrong that shouldn't feel that
way you should be able to leave and kind
of I feel like this is a camp how the
crushing pressure on Ronda shoulders now
she has to worry about
getting coaches actually seems dutchy
deems fit I you know I agree because
clearly like you know a lot more about
specific coaching camps and like her
specific coach than I do
um but I understand people and how you
know your life and career works and then
it's not always easy to make a decision
just based on what's good for your
career absolutely it's a lot of other
things II um I think well because you're
saying it you know if she switched
coaches do you think it would be like
what are the what are the chances of her
physically getting better fighter wise
thousand per thousand thousand thousand
she's not been taught professional
kickboxing Muay Thai boxing literally
any of the stand-up skills specifically
from a [ __ ] trained professional I'm
sorry there's just so many camps out
there with coaches who who have
literally like developed fighters into
boxers in them anime like giving them a
stand-up game like Demian Maia okay hmm
I'm actually blanking on where he trains
but I know for a fact that Demian Maia
at one point was a jujitsu powerhouse
and all he did was choke [ __ ]
out until he realized the UFC was more
than that he wasn't just grappling he
needed to learn how to [ __ ] punch and
then he did and now he is an amazing
fighter because he learned how to
[ __ ] stand up fight Rousey as much as
she can knock someone out has knocked
people out you know has stood and you
know exchanged punches that doesn't mean
she's refined as a stand-up fighter and
I think once she is she's going to be so
much more dangerous than she's ever been
um how like okay on a scale of like
everybody a lot of people some people
just you how many people do you think
would agree with the statement that she
should switch coaches like how much is
this being talked about right now you
know that I I'm a big you know fan of
our MMA I go there quite a bit of being
on there for years and if there's for
the most part there's good discussions
going on over there
and I would say it's 100% unanimous in
the reddit anime community that she
should move camps but that's that's a
niche that's a small group so I would
say about 40% of the entire world who
knows about this thing she should switch
camps you know the other 60% is made up
half of people who don't know what a
camp is and half people who are like no
you got your ass kicked I went up to it
you know what I mean like the casual
fans well I mean if we were to weigh the
pros and cons right now she would she
would physically get better which I did
a lot of people agree with yeah um but
she was the biggest con I think is just
that she would know she don't hurt
somebody's family it's emotional it's a
big it's you know devastate his life and
career and livelihood which is we're not
something easy to sit with no it's not
but it's so wrong that that's how it
would go that's so wrong well yeah I I'm
but it's a factor that I might I might
agree with you there and that you know
it when you are as important I this is
why I value Ronda so much I've you heard
someone really important in the history
of athletics I think she's a really
important person I don't think anyone
doesn't feel that way but like we need
her to fulfill her potential as far as
she can go because it every single time
that she does anything it like is just
busting down doors and is breaking these
waves for people like we need her to go
as far as she can professionally and
you're absolutely right I think that
what she you know by staying with her
coach for so long and being with him she
has done something so incredibly
honorable and wonderful for him and
their relationship together but I think
I think if he's a mature adult yep he
needs to realize that he probably will
have a career you're a hundred rest of
his life yeah and she I think maybe they
would need to have a frank and honest
conversation that at this point it's not
just about him in Ronda it's about the
fact that she kind of has a higher
purpose right now different feel yeah
but by not trading all of these things
like she's doing herself and the sport
and you know just in history women's
athletic history it just disservice by
not you know pushing herself in her
limits too as far as she wants or the
potential she clearly wants to be the
best
she always has she always will you know
she she will work as hard as she can to
be the best but there is something
holding her back and it's not her work
ethic or desire to learn yeah it's it's
emotional yeah no I agree
I you know there's nothing wrong with
that it's like it's it's true so that's
not it's not the way I that's
frustrating I did I was not aware of
yeah you let you remember him from her
season of Ultimate Fighter like he was
starting fights with other coaches like
he's not the greatest guy like he's not
he's not well-liked either
um but unfortunately he got his claws in
with Ronda early on so they have this
bond where she you know it feels
attached or you know you know like she
owes him something when in reality I
mean let's be honest here the guy has a
name just because of Rousey like nobody
would give a [ __ ] who Edmond Harvard in
was if if she didn't train with it
period
well I mean but think about coming up in
your athletics when you have somebody
you know a coach or someone that's
really like holds a special place in
your heart you're never not even your
heart it might we don't know it could be
like such an integral part of her life
and her job that she might not be able
to really function without well here's
okay here's something that's but that's
how big that change oh you're right
you're right you're right I don't know
what Rhonda is I don't know what she's
thinking about when it comes to that
what I want mate what about this like
what if she goes to Emma's like hey
obviously we have a hole in our game we
need to fix it what I'm going to do is
I'm going to continue training with you
four days a week the other three days or
two days or whatever the [ __ ] I'm going
to go learn some kickboxing it's one of
those some more
Tai I think that's a good solution he
mean he he is that kind of guy that
might be a little butthurt but like if
she didn't want to get rid of him that
seems like a fair solution all of the
how not a profound line leading up to my
rematch I'm gonna fly
Lamarque delle grazie out to California
and I'm gonna have him work on the myths
with me for six months
while I also train with you there you
know your there's a mill I mean I'm just
saying that's a possibility
like people do that you know maybe it's
not like a way maybe they're a long way
yeah but no you're absolutely it's it's
kind of scary how you're like the things
you're saying I you know like how she
probably feels like it might be all
against the logical move but it doesn't
make it any less intense well yeah we'll
think of any like anybody in a situation
that's completely life-changing
take for example totally unrelated
somebody that is going through a divorce
or debating whether or not they should
get a divorce yeah you know just because
you know it's not right for your life
like this person you shouldn't be with
them anymore it doesn't make it any
easier or less difficult to you know
move on or make that giant step or
change like I imagine the closest thing
that I can come to comparing her
relationship with her coach is like a
divorce yeah like you were with this
person day in and day out you rely on
them you're dependent on them and vice
versa
like there's just so much codependence
in terms of career life probably
emotional support all of those things
you know that go into your life it would
be a divorce and to tell somebody you
know even if he was an abusive husband
they're not married okay I'm making a
[ __ ] comparison but like even a
person in an abusive relationship you
can have the world telling you you need
to leave but that it's much more
complicated than everyone else great
area than everyone else know so I think
this would be comparable to like a
somebody getting a divorce
everyone being like just just switch
coaches just leave him I imagine it is
very difficult and that is just another
reason why this is a career-defining
moment I agree just another reason
there's a slew of reasons right now
that is just another one of them not and
I I think that she that there might be
some ways to not get rid of him to maybe
have different coaches do different
things not cause that damage because I'm
not I can't rule out the fact that if
she you know got rid of this person
that's been there for her in so many
ways that she could just emotionally
crumble which doesn't matter how in
great shape you are not matter you so
right you emotionally crumble a person's
a person it what what the [ __ ] doesn't
matter if you get great coaches you
fight I can't function all good points
I'm honestly very curious to see what
happens this is one of the few things
that I've been very very very closely
following and I'm going to until she
steps foot back on that canvas because
this is just it's an intriguing thing
and it really is something that in 20
years we're all gonna look back on and
say wow that lost defined her you know
she either completely overcame it or it
ruined her you know and it's just it's
that powerful of a moment the the flux
were in right now with Rhonda like it's
it's happening right now the change
that's going to define what direction
she goes but um yeah I don't know I'm I
would also just touch much I would also
just like to throw in the fact that it
was really really like nice to see Holly
home win and I think the cheap CD burner
to be a very nice person and that she
worked her [ __ ] out ya know for sure
so it was incredible to watch she had
sportsmanship she had respect she gave
nothing but props to Rhonda I mean yeah
you couldn't ask for a better champion
yeah I think if anything it's wonderful
to have a new female [ __ ] MMA fighter
to be a fan of yeah you know absolutely
actually you know only good things can
come out of that as far as I'm concerned
as long as she doesn't you know blow a
bunch of [ __ ] cocaine up her nose and
then hit people with their power yeah
and that shit's not cheap you gotta
watch her credit with that better
download the credit card man
probably because she's getting this cash
now and she's gotta know how to make a
credit score better from it so she
should text Jenna Julian to eighty nine
eight hundred to get her link to her
free Credit Karma app so she can start
monitoring her credit
for free and that's just me talking
about Holly Holm you guys well no you
should do the same thing
thanks Credit Karma for sponsoring us
thank you make sure to check them out
guys and thank you Marvel Furby marble I
want to hear what he has to contribute
can you put his mouth to the mic on here
oh good noise oh we struggle noises huh
good contribution ready good I said so
nice and quiet so you just want to sit
on my lap in my max well thank you guys
for hanging out with us for this podcast
watching listening we appreciate it yeah
let us know your thoughts please do
please Simon yeah some of you guys are
real big yeah
seasons Sonia all you guys hit us up
with those comments I want to hear what
you guys have to say and we'll see you
guys next week for another podcast yeah
and maybe we'll have another dog oh yeah
no not wait it's a beauty camera thanks
for being here button alright see you
guys
you